the solution was found by another
British mathematician in cryptographer
Clifford Cox Cox needed to construct a
special kind of one-way function called
a trapdoor one-way function this is a
function that is easy to compute in one
direction get difficult to reverse
unless you have special information
called the trapdoor for this he turned
to modular exponentiation which we
introduced as clock arithmetic in the
diffie-hellman key exchange as follows
take a number
raise it to some exponent divided by the
modulus and output the remainder this
can be used to encrypt a message as
follows
imagine Bob has a message which is
converted into a number M he then
multiplies his number by itself
e times where e is a public exponent
then he divides the result by a random
number N and outputs the remainder of
the division this results in some
numbers see this calculation is easy to
perform
however given only C E and n it is much
more difficult to determine which M was
used because we'd have to resort to some
form of trial and error so this is our
one-way function that we can apply to M
easy to perform but difficult to reverse
it is our mathematical lock
now what about the key the key is the
trapdoor some piece of information that
makes it easy to reverse the encryption
we need to raise C to some other
exponent say D which will undo the
initial operation applied to M and
return the original message M so both
operations together is the same as M to
the power of E all raised to the power
of D which is the same as M to the power
of e times D e is the encryption D is
the decryption therefore we need a way
for Alice to construct e and D which
makes it difficult for anyone else to
find D this requires a second one-way
function which is used for generating D
and for this he looked back to Euclid
over